our first speaker is vivian londo who
will talk about
towards local testability for quantum
coding
thank you thank you for giving me the
opportunity to talk here
so i'm going to to talk about um
quantum locally testable codes and this
is joint work with
anthony varga and jill zimmer
ah let me minimize this
um okay
so uh so this talk is about quantum
codes and i will start with the
um a controversial sentence that um
classical ldpc codes are well understood
in the sense that if you pick a random
matrix um sorry a priority check matrix
at random
it gives you a linear number of logical
bits and a linear minimum distance
and you can decode such a code
efficiently with a belief propagation
algorithm and what i mean
with classical ldbc codes are are well
understood
is and what i really want to do is to
contrast this with quantum ldpc codes
which are um way less understood
and first let me define quantum ldbc
codes
so um they are defined by
constraints that are local which makes
them ldpc
and just like classical dpc codes if
a state satisfies all such local
constraints
then it belongs to the code space and
this is uh
this is what defines the code so um
when when i'm saying that they are fully
understood what i mean is that
the the best scaling for the number of
logical qubits
and for the minimum distance is not
known for quantum ldpc codes
and it's um and it's not always clear
how to efficiently
decode them and what i would like to
investigate in this talk is
what property of a quantum code makes
decoding
easy so
the the first um
the first guess for a good decoder for
quantum pc code is to use the same
decoder as for classical codes
namely belief propagation but this
doesn't work
because quantum codes have lots of small
cycles
it comes from the fact that they are
ldpc and another approach
is to use local decoders and this works
much better for some codes
notably for hyperbolic 4d codes and also
for
quantum extender codes and what's
interesting here
is that in the case of quantum expander
codes for instance
what makes the decoder the local decoder
called the small set flip
work is that such codes um
satisfy the they have they have good
sumness
soundness they satisfy the falling
inequality
that um the syndrome of an error
is at least well it is proportional to
the size of the error itself
um so quantum expander code satisfied
its property but
only for errors that are small enough
and this is sufficient to show that the
small set flip decoder
works for such codes and in the case of
hyperbolic codes the fact that local
decoder works
also comes from inequalities that are
very similar to some
inequalities namely isoparametric
inequalities
satisfied for low weight errors
so um having this inequality
is not sufficient to say that the code
is locally testable
when it holds only for small enough
errors it has to hold for any error of
any size
and if we had such codes then
there would be some nice implications
and
in the case of classical codes their
existence
led to some very nice results in
complexity theory
so let me now talk more specifically
about quantum localities table codes
the connection with uh complexity theory
is not as clear as in the classical case
but there are some
hints that um some links with
hamiltonian complexity
and also it has some links as i was
saying before with
good decoders and and among others with
the single shot decoding
so to to define formally what a quantum
locally disabled code
is i first need to have a notion of
distance to code
and weight of the syndrome so let me
first
formalize the notion of distance to code
it's possible to define states that are
a distance
at most t from the code space and by
taking
a weighted sum of states that are a
distance at most t but not
at most t minus one you get the distance
operator
and um this gives the formal definition
of a quantum
locally testable code when the
hamiltonian operator associated with
this code
is greater than the this
distance operator renormalized
and finding such quantum codes is hard
there are only
two cons tunan constructions the first
one was
by matthew hastings in 2017 and
the second one is in this work and it
gives a slightly better
soundness constant
so um to emphasize that
it's hard to find locally testable
quantum codes let me um
first say that most the most famous
quantum codes are not locally testable
for example the tory codes
uh if you have a a string like chain of
errors it has
syndrome only two so constant syndrome
which shows that it's not locally
testable
and as i was saying before for quantum
expander codes
um if you take errors of weight square
root of the number of qubits
um then they won't be uh they can have a
constant weight syndrome so
they won't be locally testable either
now this um this brings me to
to the construction itself of this work
it's called the
hemi cubic code and um
it has the following parameters only one
logical qubit
and a distance that is that grows like
square root of the number of
physical qubits um it also comes with an
efficient decoder
and in in the work we have a
generalization
with more than one logical qubits with a
polynomial number of logical qubits
so the the construction itself comes
from the
the n-dimensional cube it's not exactly
the n-dimensional cube you have to
take quotients so take a quotient of
this cube so
identify opposite edges opposite
vertices and opposite faces
and when doing so so and using the the
usual homological construction
um for instance by identifying qubits
with two faces with squares
you get a quantum code with one logical
qubit and it's possible to show that
the product of the two minimum distances
is the number of physical qubits
and to show local stability is the same
as showing
feeling inequalities for such a code uh
that's because the syndrome of a
homological code
is the is like the boundary of a of the
of the faces corresponding to the qubits
that that had an error
um and to do this uh we actually
leveraged the word
uh a work by doterra from 2012 to show
that in a cube
you always have a small feeling um and
and
and this feeling can be uh of weight
linear in the weight of the air
um so the the proof is recursive you
actually sense
the you find the beginning of a filling
that sends
all the error to the left side of the n
dimensional hypercube
and then you can iterate with an n minus
one dimensional hypercube
and this works well for the cube the
problem is that our quantum code is
actually
based on a hemi cube a cube with
identifications
so we had to um adjust the proof and by
doing so we lose
a log factor which explains why the the
sum is constant is not optimal in our
work
but we actually conjecture that the the
soundness constant of the cube is the
right one even for the hemi cube
um so so to to summarize and give some
perspectives
uh we gave two constructions of quantum
codes
based on n-dimensional cubes um
the first one uh there is only one
identification and this gives only one
logical qubit
and we can show that such codes are
locally testable
and then a general version has a
polynomial number of logical qubits
that is harder to analyze and the main
open question is to see
for which growth
of logical qubits we can find some
quantum locally testable codes thank you
you uh the next talk is sharp
threshold rates for random quotes
uh
with nikolaris
yes great uh thank you very much for the
introduction um this is based on
joint work with uh vancouver swami
jonathan meshach
with silas and mary ruders
so uh the topic for this talk as i'm
sure mostly talks in the session are
you know error correcting codes which
are means for two parties to communicate
even if they are connected by
some sort of unreliable channel so alice
here wishes to transmit a message to bob
but for whatever reason the channel
might introduce some errors
so um how would these parties deal with
this well they'll use what we call a
code
which is just sort of a set of possible
strings that alice might transmit across
the channel
and we'd like that this set of codes has
some sort of error correcting
capabilities
and this is in tension with the the rate
of the code which is somehow a measure
of how
much information alice is transmitting
every time she sends a code word
and so in coding theory we're basically
interested in understanding what sort of
trade-offs we could hope for
between error tolerance and rate
in this talk let's just for concreteness
think of the alphabet sigma as being
finally filled with two elements for our
constant q maybe even q equals two if
you like
and we'll let the block length end tend
to infinity
so uh specifically in this talk we'll be
interested in uh random codes
which you could just think of as sort of
a uniformly random subset of the space
sigma to the end
or if you prefer with uh you know to be
a bit more precise
uh we'll actually say that each element
is included independently with
probability chosen so that the expected
rate of the resulting subset c
is our which is the rate of the random
code
and so why would we consider these
things well this is a combinatorial you
know
codes are commentarial objects and
there's this uh interesting phenomenon
that in combinatorics random objects
often are the best
for a given problem um also uh
from our coding theoretic perspective
they're used in proofs of many classical
coding theorems
uh as an example you know one of the
very first theorems that was ever proved
in coding theory uh
china's noisy channel coding theorem
uses random codes um they also appear in
certain proofs so say the gilbert
barshma found
another example which is particularly
relevant to this work
is a list of coding ballistic coding
capacity theorem
so to describe this uh what this theorem
is i'll first say what it means for code
to be less decodable
um i have the definition written
formally above but uh informally
it basically means that whenever i take
a ball of radius p which is just you
know the set of all strings that differ
from
the center x and at most p n coordinates
um i never uh collect too many code
words so say they're always less than
capital l
code words and any uh fall of radius p
so uh what does the list of coding
capacity theorem tell us it essentially
tells us
how large the rate can be um if we would
like to have a code which is
p l list decodable for reasonable values
of l
specifically um if the rate is at most
one minus h sub q of p minus epsilon
or a sub q of p here is this q or
entropy function if you're not familiar
with it you could just think of say the
binary entropy function
um uh we know that there exists
uh linear uh there exist codes that are
listed codable up to radius p with lists
of size only one over epsilon but
whenever the rate r exceeds
um one minus a sub q of p plus uh
epsilon say
then we can't really have listed coding
in any meaningful sense unless we allow
you know the less size to be exponential
in n
um what's interesting about this theorem
uh from our perspective is that to prove
the possibility result
we actually use a random code so
essentially one chooses a random code of
rate one minus
q of p minus epsilon and shows that with
extremely high probability it will be p
whenever epsilon's decodable
okay so this is sort of a first example
of what one might think of as a phase
transition
now i'm going to do a somewhat annoying
thing uh somehow when this work was more
convenient for us to talk about
properties like the property of not
being less decodable
so um what did the list of coding
capacity theorem tell us well it said
that when the rate r was very small
a random code is not list decodable with
a very low probability
so you know with probability very close
to zero will be not list decodable
then at some sort of cutoff it goes from
being not list decodable
sorry it goes from being not not list
decodable to uh list
to uh not list decodable um or a very
narrow window
so we have this sort of a phase
transition where the probability goes
from being very close to zero to very
close to one over a narrow window
and so while the listed counting
capacity theorem gives us some
information oh
alrighty there we go um well the list
accounting capacity theorem gives us
some information about
uh you know these sorts of transitions
we could ask for more information
for example like what sort of properties
um would have would experience such a
phase transition for random care
random codes and also can we compute
kind of this this threshold rate where
we go from
you know the probability of being very
close to zero to very close to one
uh say a motivating example where say
the listed coding capacity theorem
doesn't tell us anything
what if we care about something like p
comma ten list of coding where the list
size is you know
fixed to this constant ten can we say
anything about what sort of um
threshold rate we could get and do we
even have this sort of sharp threshold
so uh what do we do in this work well
essentially we
answer this question affirmatively what
we do specifically is we characterize
this threshold rate for a large class of
properties and uh on this slide i'll try
to informally outline what we do
um so first of all we take the
perspective of
looking at mini code properties and we
know that they're satisfied if and only
if a minimal set of vectors happen to
lie in the code
so for example if we want to talk about
the property of not being p
list decodable um this uh a code will
not be p a list decodable if and only
if it contains some minimal set of l
vectors from
a radius p ball right so we have kind of
all sorts of these minimal sets and we
just need to ask when is it the case
that a random code is likely to contain
one of them
and um sort of building on some previous
work and also using a concept from
information theory called types
there's a natural way to go from these
sets of
sets of code words which define the
property into collections of
what we call types i won't be able to in
this
short time explain exactly how we do
this but all i need
to know for the remainder of the talk is
that types are some sort of special
distributions
okay so we can talk about the entropy of
these types and things like that
and then essentially uh based on what
we've done so far we could say that a
property is satisfied if and only if
some set of code words with you know one
of these types happens to lie in the
code
right so we can go from talking about
some property to a set of types and we
just need to ask
when a set of code words with one of
these types happens to lie in our random
code
and as a final step which is actually
sort of one of the more subtle
issues in this work we define what we
call symmetric properties
um which include things like list of
coding and some of the generalizations
like sales recovery
and we're able to compute uh the sharp
threshold rate for any symmetric
property
so one of the challenges here was to
come up with a definition of property
which was you know broad enough to
include the things that we were
interested in
but also you know narrow enough that we
could give a very very precise answer
um so allow me to briefly you know
show what the characterization of the
threshold is so basically we can say
that whenever you have a symmetric
property which is defined by the
inclusion of a set of
b vectors whose uh type lie in some
you know set of set of types t the
threshold r star
is always given by uh some sort of you
know
a quantity which depends on the entropy
of the types in the set t
so recall i said that all these types
you know we can think of them as
distributions
so talking about their entropy makes
sense actually we sort of use the qra
entropy just because we're working
over um alphabets of size q
okay uh so that's all i was uh planning
to say in
my eight minutes so all i did was sort
of this first bullet point the
characterization of the threshold for
symmetric properties
however in the you know in the paper and
also hinted at in the full version of
this talk
we also um talked about a few other uses
of this
uh characterization of the threshold
rate so we could give analytic
estimates for the threshold rate for
something like noisy list recovery which
is
just kind of a generalization of list of
coding we also show that we can always
compute the threshold rate
um as long as you admit some small
additive error
um we could even precisely pin down the
threshold rate for something like uh
you know we have the list of size three
say um for binary random codes we can
precisely pin down the threshold rate
and also for a certain class of codes
called first perfect caching codes
great that's all i wanted to say thank
you very much
our next speaker is pharaoh labe on high
entropy dual functions
and locally recordable codes
yes let me
go full screen here
okay can you see the slides
i guess yes so um
my name is faro khabib this is a joint
work with job briet
on high entropy dual functions and
locally decodable codes
so i will first explain
a certain interesting connection between
local decodable codes and
xamarin's theorem with random
differences and show
how certain objects called dual
functions
play a role here
so local quarterback codes
encode some message links some message
of
length m into a code word of length
say n and they have the property that
um you can retrieve a single message bit
with high probability by only querying a
small number of codeword symbols in this
case two
even after partial corruption
some examples of hammer of
local equivalent codes are rmr code this
is a two query i'll
say of length exponential in m
and the read more code generalizes to
q queries and has length exponential in
m to the power one over q minus one for
a long time this has been the best
codes of this days and in
breakthrough work yohanne constructs
matched so-called matching vector codes
which are three query lds of length
exponential in m to the power 1 over t
where he uses large families of matching
vectors in fpm
from our sign prime p equal to 2 to the
t minus 1.
so as of now the largest mercen prime
has t
at least 77 million so as you can see
this is a huge improvement over
three query uh read mirror codes
and later uh flamenco constructs um
three query other states of sub
exponential length using matching
vectors in
z mod l to power n with l composite
and as was noted in the previous talk
most of the time
the probabilistic method can beat a
certain constructions
um easily for example
expanded graphs but in the case of ldsas
this is not the case the probabilistic
method has not beaten
explicit constructions here so
a certain framework uh where this can be
done
is the framework by briet de villen gopi
where a special instance
is given by zamrelli's theorem with
random differences
and uses the probabilistic method to
construct all this ace
and i will now explain what this uh
summaries theorem
differences is but first generalist
theorem
so suppose you have a wheel with a lot
of spokes
and say you remove 99 of them
so these are the remaining ones and then
if the number of spokes that you started
with was very large
then the remaining ones will always
contain some structured subsets
the red spokes here and the structure is
that
uh subsequent spokes have equal distance
precisely any subset from
a from one up to n with a having a
positive fraction of all the elements
contains a non-trivial k term arithmetic
progression
which is a sequence of the form x x plus
d x plus 2 d
dot dot x plus k minus 1 d
and this is true when n is sufficiently
large
so a certain refinement of this is
called semresterometranum differences
and here the question is what is the
smallest row k
for which a bernoulli rocket and set d
inside an ability group g
we can do this for any beading group um
such that it has a property that same
reduced theorem holds with common
difference inside the
probability at least one half so what i
mean is
i want this statement to be true
but i restrict my common difference the
step size here
to be ins inside a bernoulli roku random
subset
from say the interval from r to n or any
a bidding group and it is this
row k that you try to find
and the this probabilistic framework of
bread very goopy
uses this as follows they show that
there exists k query ldss with message
length
omega row k of that group g
times n times n and codeword length
of n where n is the size of the group
so if roque is large for a certain group
that gives you
good all they says
so um
in this in this framework it's um
important to understand
these the upper bounds on okay so we can
understand how what kind of codes we can
find from this
connection and the conjecture by
franchinaki's list engine variable
state that this probability okay for the
group z mode n
is at most log n divided by n
and if you work out the details the
truth of this conjecture would imply
that
uh in this framework somebody
stereomaterial differences cannot give
better all they says
than the hallmark code over uh
and similarly it is expected uh but
not explicitly stated as a conjecture
that over fbn
this probability row k is at most n to
the power k minus one divided by
p to the n again if this is true
the red stereo and random differences
cannot give better lds than
the read motor codes of this group
so in this work we mainly focus on the
finite field case
and this this explicit conjecture
is uh mainly motivated by a conjecture
in higher or free analysis
which is um and this conjecture is
a finite field analog of conjecture made
by francis naches in ergoback theory
and the precise conjecture
is or this is rather imprecise
and it says that objects called dual
functions can be approximate arbitrary
closely
in l infinity distance by low degree
polynomial phase functions i will
explain what are these objects later
but for now conjecture 2
implies conjecture 1. so
um if conjecture 2 was true then this
upper bound holds and we cannot get
better with
codes than read more codes using this
probabilistic construction but our main
result
is that conjecture 2 is false
so let me define what these objects are
so an orthotime function is a function
from
fbn to complex numbers it's given by
some pattern i j k
and it takes the following form for some
functions f g
and it's an expectation
[Music]
so what are polynomial phase functions
these are
simply a form a bit rate of unique
power polynomial p of n variables
of degree at most k so the conjecture
states that any order 3 dual function
can be written as some convex
combination
of these of these functions of degree
of polymorph phases of degree at most
two
and the error term in this decomposition
uh is small everywhere at this has small
infinity number and make sure that that
is false
and in fact we can define order k l
functions for any k
and that's our result says that we
cannot
approximate such functions using only
polynomial phases of low degree
and a proof sketch goes as follows
we showed up there there for infinite
primes there is
some set of arcade dual functions
such that it contains a height
dimensional hypercube
then um you use the fact that there are
not so many polynomial faces
and then we conclude by using some tools
from geometric function analysis
it's a very rough sketch and let me
conclude by some open problems
so the counter examples we found we
don't have really good control over them
over the patterns and we'd like to have
uh examples for three epidural functions
and uh maybe for even for more primes
like uh
for large enough primes there should
always be comfort examples
and upper bounds on some redstone the
general difference is still open
so thanks for your attention
thanks um
the next paper
is error correcting codes for
uncompressed messages
and offer grossman will be giving the
call
hey cool
if you can't see this someone speak up
but i'll be talking about error
correcting codes for uncompressed
messages and this is joint with
justin holmgren
cool and so here's the setup that we're
all familiar with there's like alice she
has some message
in our case this picture of an apple
that she wants to send to bob
and there's a channel where there's some
adversary that can corrupt in our case
up to three percent of the bits three
percent is arbitrary but
yep and here we'll assume that alice's
polynomial
a polynomial time machine bob is a
polynomial time machine
all right so she wants to somehow send
it to bob so that even if there's errors
bob can still like recover the original
message
all right great cool and so the standard
approach when we do these things
is kind of first we compress the message
and then we use an error correcting code
so it's kind of a two-step process so
the reason it's important at first to
compress the messages
is like well if you have this picture of
an apple and you have some image
compression algorithm that can
in a lossless way compress it to say
half its size
then at the end of the day you're going
to be saving like half your bits you're
going to be sending half
as many bits so kind of there's two ways
in general to save you can either like
get better compression algorithms for
whatever type of message you're sending
or you can get better error correcting
codes just like this two-step
out this two-step process right and in
this case an error correcting code is
something like this it's a pair of
algorithms an encoding and a decoding
algorithm
so that whenever i encode something add
errors and decode it
i get the original thing it's just a
standard error correcting code
definition
and this is where the new stuff starts
as we kind of ask is this the best we
can do is is it really true that the
best we can do is to compress the
message and then using error correcting
code
and it turns out that that's not always
the case and so let's think for example
about a situation where
our message we don't know how to
compress it to the information theoretic
limit
right for example um
it might be the case that like because
of um
computational limitations we don't like
we can't compress it to the
to the limit or maybe we just don't know
what the algorithm is
or maybe there is some structure and we
don't know what the structure is so we
can't use it
but there's a bunch of reasons why like
our compression algorithm
might not reach the information
theoretic limit and then what happens is
when we go to the step
two our message still has some sort of
structure
so using this like very general error
correcting code is kind of overkill
right there's still some sort of
structure so even if we can't kind of
harvest the structure to get better
compression algorithms
it might still be the case that we're
able to use the structure to get
better error correcting goes for that
specific message or for that specific
class of message
messages so the idea is
in a sense to like combine one and two
or just to kind of
like throw away this compress and use an
error correcting code and think
like like what is it that we want um in
general and how can we
leave the standard approach and see if
we can get something better
so here's the new approach the new
approach will be we'll try to correct
create an air correcting code that
guarantees
that it will definitely work for all
reasonable messages so the way we can
think of these reasonable messages is
for example in the case of images it's
it's everything that actually looks like
an image so for example
a picture of an apple is reasonable and
something that's a random
matrix of pixels is not reasonable
right and you can think like a picture a
random array of pixels is not
compressible
whereas a picture of an apple is
compressible so
yep so the idea is we want to somehow be
able to
to get error correcting codes that work
for these reasonable messages
all right so here's here's a definition
um
an error correcting code code for a set
s
where s we can think of as the set of
all reasonable images
it's an encoding and decoding algorithm
so that for all x and s
when i encode it at errors in decode i
get x again
right so the difference from our
previous definition
is that here my guarantee is only over x
and s earlier i had a guarantee over all
0 1
to the k and now i have a guarantee over
x and s
and this is actually what we care about
right like if you're alice and you're
sending a message to bob and you're
sending this image of an apple
you you only care about how the error
correcting code behaves on
like actual reasonable images right we
think of s as a set of reasonable images
so you only care about how it behaves on
these reasonable images because you're
never going to be sending bob a random
array of pixels you're only going to
send them things that actually look like
images
so having an air correcting code that's
guaranteed to work on these things that
look like images is exactly what you
want
so this leads to the question of like
okay for what sets like this can you
build this thing but before we talk
about what sets we can build this thing
let's just
like see an example so the the
definition is super clear
so suppose alice has this picture of an
apple and she wants to send it to bob
so this picture of an apple is an s
because it's it's a reasonable image
right so we can imagine it's an s so
then bob gets it and their correcting
code succeeds
if alice has random noise this is this
doesn't look like an image so
it's not an s so bob gets this other
thing that's different
and the error correcting code fails but
we don't actually care because alice is
not going to send something like this in
the first place
right so here i'm always thinking of s
as the set of these
like reasonable images but you know if
you're sending different types of data
you can think of
s accordingly right like if you're
sending english text you can think of s
as everything that
is not just like random keyboard
matching but everything that actually
looks like english text
all right cool so with this in mind now
the main question is for what
s's can we construct these things so
here's our result
and here i just like picked parameters
so there wouldn't be a bunch of
um like weird expressions
so we we show for example that for every
s
set s that's small enough where you can
determine membership
in s and polynomial time so given an x
you can tell whether it's an s or not in
polynomial time
then there exists an error correcting
code for s
for three percent errors that gives you
expands the message by a factor of one
point seven
four right and to compare with this
which with what we've known before is
what was known before if you did the old
approach was 2.52
if you use this old approach of like
just using a normal error correcting
code none of the
not these error correcting codes for a
specific set then after our work you can
get 2.27
but the the main point is that they're
both far from 1.74 so using this old
approach
gives you something much worse than the
new approach
cool and yeah it's it's worth noting in
general like here i just picked
parameters because the
it's kind of complicated to write the
exact uh
like the exact expression so i figured
picking parameters would
would be a better example but in general
there's just a continuous trade-off
between
the size of s the amount of errors and
the rate
cool and then like
30 second like the approach the
approaches uses list decoding so let's
decoding i have a message and then
when i decode it i get a list and the
idea is like
kind of if you're bob and you get this
list that looks like this
you can see that a lot of things kind of
look like nothing and then one other
thing looks like an apple so if you're
bob and you receive these you can
kind of guess that the apple is the is
the message that alice sent
so formally the idea is we kind of want
to create these list decodable codes
and augment them so that we can
guarantee that with
very high probability only one of the
elements in the list will be an
s so then we can check each one of these
elements in the list if it's an s or not
and then we just take the one that is an
s
yep that's it thanks
thanks
and the last speaker is
you while dagon on the entropy of lies
playing 20 questions with a liar
hello uh yeah so this is a joint work
with
uh yuval filmos daniel kane and
shy mohan and this work is about
a 20 questions game so let's start by
describing
a simplest fire in this game
so it is played by two parties alice and
bob
where bob thinks of some object from a
finite set
and alice's goal is to reveal this
object
using yes no questions
so here you can see a strategy of
alice and alice wants to ask
as few questions as possible
so in this simple variant of this game
the optimal strategy will ask login
questions
and this is achieved using a simple
binary search
so now let me add i will add two
different complications of this game
so the first complication is by allowing
bob
to answer some of the questions with
light
and he is allowed at most k lies
and alice would have to be to figure out
the true element
always regardless of the lies and this
was studied in prior work
already in the 60s and 80s
and the optimal strategy requires an
additional
k times log log n questions
so that was the first generalization and
let me
explain the second generalization
and here we assume some probability
distributions
over uh the elements that uh bob selects
this probability we call it mu and alice
knows this distribution and her goal
is to minimize the number of questions
that she asks
in expectation where the expectation
is over this probability distribution
so let's see some examples so here we
have uh
the potato will be selected with
probability one half
the cat with 0.3 the dog with 0.2
and and what is the expected number of
questions that alice asks in this
strategy
so it can be easily computed
to equal one and a half questions
on expectation over a random object uh
so once we define this uh
[Music]
this setting now we can ask uh what is
the
optimal strategy for alice and first
in the setting with no lies
and the optimal strategy is easily
obtained
using a huffman code and it asks
roughly the entropy of the distribution
number of questions on average
where the entropy is just the sum
over all probabilities mu i of mu
i times log one over mu i
so i defined two extensions of this game
first by introducing lies and then by
uh introducing a probability
distribution over the elements
and both were studied separately in
prior work
and in this work we study a mixture of
these settings
namely both a distribution and a lying
bob to lie
and in order to show
the guarantees of obtaining this paper
so we let's recap the prior
settings so it's a deterministic setting
with no lines
we have login questions
with lines we have an additional k times
log log n questions now in the
distributional setting
the login is replaced by the entropy of
the distribution
and in this paper we show that in the
distributional setting with
lies we can further replace the log log
n
by a term that we call the h2 of the
distribution
which is just the sum over the
probabilities
of the probability times log
log 1 over the probability
and and we noted that uh if
we uh substitute the uniform
distribution
into mu then we get the same uh
same number of questions as in the in
the
deterministic setting so this is some
kind of an extension
and and we have both upper and lower
bounds that
are with the sharp constants
and up to some lower order terms
and further the algorithm is efficiently
compute computable
and uses a binary search like
algorithm so it uses only comparison
queries
and for this reason uh we can apply it
to a sorting with comparison queries
so in the sorting setting uh
um so we have a noisy sorting where
uh some of the comparisons can give you
wrong answers
and we assume a distributional setting
which means some prior distribution over
the possible permutations
for example we can assume that the array
is already
partially ordered and in this setting
we can replace the n log n comparisons
with the entropy uh
over uh the of the distribution over
permutations
uh so yeah actually i have some time so
maybe
i can just oh
okay okay so uh yeah
it was closed so uh i wanted to show the
lower bound but
you can see it in the video and
uh yeah thanks for watching
so now let's open the discussion
uh you can ask questions to the speakers
store you can just discuss any general
topics
chords
sure can i ask a quick question then uh
the last speaker yuval i was wondering
so this h2 of mu quantity
um it sounds did you define this quality
or has it been
are you aware of it being used in any
previous works or
is it is it just really is it something
that popped up for the first time in
what you were doing
uh i know i mean
it's it's just that's what you get so
you have some
uh like
conditional entropy and
uh it comes from
um the expected
log one over the number of questions
uh so that's how you get it i i don't
know if it was defined before
i see so it's not like you're applying
some other fact where it appears or
anything like that it's really just
comes out of the analysis itself yeah
yeah it just comes
from the analysis
so i have the question a question to the
first speaker vivian lond
so i'm wondering is there any way how
one could transform a classical
ldpc into a quantum ldpc
um there there is a
construction called the hypergraph
product um
construction by telescene demo from 2014
and it takes it
it takes a classical dip code and makes
quantum ellipse codes
it's it's like a product but you lose
some properties
of the classical code by doing so
so in terms of the minimum distance
under some mild assumption you will only
get square roots
of the minimum distance of the classical
code and
in terms of local testability you can
you can lose also uh some some soundness
property by doing this this product
okay thanks
uh i had a question for offer
um so this set
so in your work you assume that the set
is like efficiently
testable right by polynomial time
algorithm do you have any
positive or negative results about what
happens if that
set is not testable
um i think i think you can show that
there exists sets where you
can't do anything like if you pick a
random set then
i think you can show you can't really do
much
um but there might still be things that
are like
like structured and also you can't like
tell membership quickly but you can
still encode them
in this i don't know
okay
so there is a question in qna by mayank
the question is to offer grossman what
is the complexity of
new contextually
error correcting code with negligible
order
with respect to the baseline approaches
we can can you see that again or is it
written somewhere
it's a it's on there um what is the
complexity
with respect to the baseline approaches
so it's
it's uh it's called polynomial time i
don't know i don't
know exactly how the polynomial time
compares with the standard approaches
but basically everything we do is we
just take like like known list decodable
codes and then we augment them a little
so whatever complexity
your list decodable codes have this is
going to have the same complexity as
them
um yeah
um if i can ask another question then um
can you say anything about the list
decodable codes which you use
um you can you can use um basically
and you need them to be like to both
have a
to be both like efficiently efficiently
list decodable and they
they need to have like some
combinatorialist decodable properties
so um so i mean
something like uh like you know uh
folded read solomon code or even just a
read solving code let's decode what the
johnson bound that would already
give you something or um yeah you get
something from
from any list decodable you get code you
get you get like an improvement but if
you want to
be like get the best bounds you have to
be
kind of careful about okay
yeah yeah but even just using like the
most most standard things will
give you improvements
do not like the best bound that we
achieve
okay
also uh i guess i could ask another
question to the second speaker
um so um if i understood correctly there
were sort of two conjectures and there
was a conjecture which you refuted which
would have implied the other conjecture
uh which was sort of about the you know
the bound on for okay
um do you have any any intuition as to
whether or not that bound is the correct
bound whatever it's like n to the k
minus one over
p to the something i believe do you
think that
that can yeah that expectation or
conjecture is still likely to be true
yeah so there's this uh lower bound uh
proven by
uh my coder yop briet
and it's basically uh this upper bound
that i showed
is uh uh he showed that uh this specific
lower bound holds so if this upper bound
uh
would be true then his lower bound would
be optimal and then
uh things would be fine or not so good
for this uh
probabilistic construction of the or
they say but
um yeah it's still open whether this is
um
whether this is true or not it's just
it's like a
an analog of this uh of z mod n
where um these people also uh
proved the same uh up lower bound and
then later conjecture that
this should be also the right upper
bound but it
remains open it's a hard question yeah
so if if um this conjecture on these
dual functions
would be true then this upper bounds
would be
the same as the lower bounds and so the
the
the counter examples of dual functions
that we
gave actually do not correspond to
certain
dual functions that are called three ap
dual functions so or
kap k term arithmetic progression dual
functions
so where the pattern is some specific
pattern
corresponding to arithmetic regressions
and
so the counter examples that we have
found we don't have good control over
the pattern
so we haven't yet constructed
counter examples to the arithmetic
progressions
so that would be interesting to look for
turning to
oh i see so you'd want the pattern to be
like 0 1 2 up to k minus 1 i guess is
that
exactly good but you can get you know
arbitrary i1 i2 ik
exactly so it's we don't have control
over that so we try to find
the certain polynomials that satisfy
certain properties
and so the pattern that we then get
after having found this polynomial that
has as good properties
then the pattern is simply the the
powers
of the of the monomials
so um i see
like the sum of the degrees of the
monomials so what do you mean all right
no so after well we'll say one plus x
plus
x to the power then the pattern would be
zero one three
the uh i think yeah
yeah and so um we actually show that
um in this in the framework that we are
using using these matching vectors
and um we we cannot find
uh polynomials uh satisfying the right
properties with
where the powers where the powers of the
monomials
are a catered progression so
the way we are doing it right now we
cannot find counter examples but
there might be another way to do it
[Music]
cool also this might be
too technical to say briefly but can you
say anything about how you know
how you get these constructions of ldcs
from these um
[Music]
uh from these sort of results on this
summary's theorem with uh
with the random differences yeah so in
this
framework um by divine gopi they
give a characterization of ld says
in terms of uh certain probability
distributions over
smooth pudding functions so it's like a
one-to-one correspondence between these
two um
between these two sets and uh somehow
these uh these thermodrum differences
can be seen
um as a special instance of these
probability distributions over
smooth boolean functions so
i i don't know exactly how this is
exactly
done so how this probability
distribution is constructed using this
generated stereotype differences but
that's basically how it's done
so there's this characterization of
ldsas in terms of certain
probability distributions of boolean
functions
and this might again be kind of
technical but uh wait are the ldcs then
smooth like
is it like you can randomly sample any
like if you're doing like a three
three query ldc is it like you can
sample any three coordinates or do they
have some sort of
it's like the query distribution
somewhat
uh smoothness is about the boolean
function so
um you want the boolean functions to be
smooth and
it's it's some kind of uh property of
some
some some spectral norm of the function
has to be
i think small like that right that makes
it smooth but it's it hasn't
it's not something to do with the log uh
with the ld says it's just
okay okay functions are smooth yeah
so if there is no further questions or
comments
let's thank everyone and
the next session is starting in two
minutes in
in the other room